>> Laura: WHEN THE MEDIA
HAVEN'T BEEN FREAKING OUT ABOUT
SEPARATING KIDS FROM THEIR
FAMILIES AND GOING TO SHELTERS
AND CALLING THEM CONCENTRATION
CAMPS COME OVER THE WEEKEND THEY
WERE FREAKING OUT ABOUT WHAT
THEY THOUGHT WAS GOING TO BE
ANOTHER NAIL IN THE COFFIN OF
DONALD TRUMP.
ANOTHER INSTANCE OF RUSSIAN
COLLUSION.
OOPS.
IT WASN'T.
LET'S WATCH.
>> MORE QUESTIONS ABOUT
POTENTIALLY ANOTHER RUSSIAN
HAVING MEETINGS CERTAINLY WAS
SOMEONE ASSOCIATED WITH THE
CAMPAIGN.
>> IN THIS CASE, ROGER STONE AND
DONALD TRUMP BEING SO CLOSE FOR
SO LONG RAISES ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT THE
PRESIDENT, THEN CANDIDATE, MAY
HAVE KNOWN ABOUT THESE RUSSIAN
CONTACTS.
>> THIS IS MY NINTH PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN AND THERE'S NEVER BEEN
ANYTHING LIKE THIS.
THE LEVEL OF CONTACTS BETWEEN
ONE CAMPAIGN AND ONE FOR
NATIONAL GOES OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
>> Laura: OKAY.
[LAUGHS]
WHERE LAUGHING HERE IN THE
STUDIO.
JOINING US TO EXPLAIN IS THE MAN
HIMSELF, ROGER STONE.
ROGER, I HAD TO TREAT YOU WITH
THAT MONTAGE BECAUSE I'M
WATCHING IT.
THAT ONE OF THEM SAY THE GUY WAS
AN FBI INFORMANT, NOT ONE OF
THEM.
>> IT'S EXTRAORDINARY.
IN MAY OF 2016, MICHAEL CAPUTO,
WHO APPEARED EARLIER WITH
SEAN HANNITY, CONTACTED ME
BECAUSE A MAN USING THE NAME
HENRY GREENBERG TURNS OUT TO BE
A PAID FBI INFORMANT, SAID HE
HAD INFORMATION THAT WOULD BE
USEFUL TO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
HE DID NOT IN FACT PROMISED IN
THE RUN-UP TO THIS MEETING DIRT
ON HILLARY CLINTON, AS REPORTED
BY SHELBY HOLLIDAY OF
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL."
CLASSIC CASE OF FAKE NEWS.
IN ANY EVENT, I RELUCTANTLY TOOK
THIS MEETING WHICH LASTED ABOUT
20 MINUTES.
IT TURNS OUT THAT HENRY
GREENBERG IS NOT HIS REAL NAME,
THAT HE IS AN FBI INFORMANT FOR
OVER 17 YEARS.
WAS DEPORTED FROM THE COUNTRY IN
2000.
HAS A 10-YEAR PRISON RECORD FOR
VIOLENT CRIME.
IS ASSOCIATED WITH RUSSIAN
ORGANIZED CRIME.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, IS IN THE
COUNTRY ON A VISA SPONSORED BY
THE MIAMI OFFICE OF THE FBI
BECAUSE HE IS PROVIDING "A
PUBLIC BENEFIT."
HE'S AN INFORMANT.
AT THIS VERY BRIEF MEETING,
MR. GREENBERG, NOT HIS REAL
NAME, THE FBI INFORMANT, FIRST
SHOWS UP WEARING A MAGA HAT AND
TRUMP T-SHIRT.
SHOWS ME PHOTOGRAPHS ON HIS
PHONE OF HE AND A WOMAN AT
VARIOUS TRUMP RALLIES AND LAYS
IT ON ME THAT HE HAS INFORMATION
DAMAGING HILLARY CLINTON AND HE
ONLY WANTS $2 MILLION FOR IT.
I REJECT HIS REQUEST FOR
$2 MILLION, AND HE LAUGHS AND
SAYS IT'S NOT YOUR MONEY I WANT.
IT IS DONALD TRUMP'S MONEY.
AND THERE IT IS GIVING UP THE
GAME.
THIS IS AN ATTEMPT TO ENTRAP ME
BUT TO COMPROMISE DONALD TRUMP.
GREENBERG OR WHATEVER HIS REAL
NAME WAS, --
>> Laura: DID HE SPEAK LIKE
THIS?
[RUSSIAN ACCENT]
DOES HE SAY I HAVE VERY GOOD
INFORMATION ON HILLARY CLINTON?
[LAUGHS]
>> THE REAL QUESTION HERE IS WHY
I DIDN'T REMEMBER A MEETING.
>> Laura: WHY DIDN'T YOU
REMEMBER?
YOU SAID -- I WANT TO PLAY --
ROGER, I'VE GOT TO BE REALLY
TOUGH ON YOU BECAUSE APRIL 19 OF
LAST YEAR, YOU SAID THIS.
LET'S WATCH.
>> I DIDN'T TALK TO ANYBODY WHO
WAS IDENTIFIABLY RUSSIAN DURING
THE TWO-YEAR RUN-UP TO THE
CAMPAIGN.
I'M NOT SURE I DID PREVIOUSLY
EITHER.
I VERY DEFINITELY CAN'T THINK OF
ANYBODY WHO MIGHT HAVE BEEN A
RUSSIAN WITHOUT MY KNOWLEDGE.
EVERYBODY IS HITTING ON TODAY.
>> THAT'S FINE.
THE QUESTION IS NOT WHY I FORGOT
A MEETING WHICH IS
INCONSEQUENTIAL IN WHICH NOTHING
IMPROPER OR ILLEGAL HAPPENS.
THE QUESTION IS WHY DOES JAMES
COMEY'S FBI RUN UNKNOWN
INFORMANT WHO IS IN THE COUNTRY
ON A VISA THROUGH THE GRACES OF
THE MIAMI FBI OFFICE FOR PUBLIC
BENEFIT IN ON ME?
HE GAVE AWAY THE GAME WHEN HE
SAID I DON'T WANT YOUR MONEY.
I WANT TRUMP'S MONEY.
THIS WAS AN EFFORT TO ENTRAP
DONALD TRUMP.
>> Laura: ROGER, WE NEED THE
DOCUMENTS ON THIS, AND I KNOW
YOU'RE GOING TO BE PURSUING THAT
BECAUSE WE NEED THE DOCUMENTS.
I WANT TO KNOW WHEN.
>> IF YOU WANT A DEMOCRAT
DOSSIER.ORG, YOU CAN SEE HIS
EXTENSIVE CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND AND ALL THE EVIDENCE
THAT HE WAS AN FBI --